[Music]
hello and welcome to playstation grenade
the month after april is here which
means i can finally bust out this meme
it's gonna be me thanks justin may sees
the video game world crank back into
action and the big games begin to take
center stage
like usual though if your wallet can't
take a pummeling this month
i found a couple of free games to tide
you over so let's do this
resident evil village is the headline
act of the month
ethan winters returns from re7 in
another first person horror fest
as he tracks down his lost daughter in a
spooky werewolf-filled vampire swarming
village
sounds delightful i'm sure you've seen
the fetishized big girl
lady dimitresk who is the main villain
of the game along with her
standard-sized daughters
all of which will continually hound
ethan as he ventures around the castle
and nearby town
it has been noted that resident evil 4
is a huge inspiration within village
combining the claustrophobic
first-person view with the exploration
and aesthetic of re-4's medieval
european town
the graphical push seen in capcom's
devil may cry 5
returns making those spaces look a
little more believable than many other
games
and when played in 4k this game is
absolutely beautiful
if you have that option i highly
recommend it the resident evil series is
known for awesome demos and as i'm
saying this there's one
on playstation but unfortunately it's a
timed demo
luckily a new demo on all platforms
drops on may the first for six days so
you can test for yourself
if you'll need adult diapers before you
buy resident evil village also includes
the online multiplayer game
reverse to celebrate 25 years of
survival horror
resident evil village drops on may 7th
on playstation xbox and pc
oh and stadia i keep forgetting that
that's a thing
here's a very interesting game to
consider hud
outlaws and legends okay not the
greatest title first we should note
the price is half that of a fully priced
game think of this as
rainbow six siege meets for honor
let me explain set in the medieval era
two teams build a squad to steal loot
from a castle or stronghold
just like siege that consists of four
members with different abilities
but that's where the similarities end
because there's a third group here
ai protectors constantly guarding the
loot you must steal
so effectively hood outlaws and legends
is pvpve
playing against other real world people
and also artificial intelligence too
the sheriff is alleged to be a brutal
combatant and guess what
he's the one holding the key to the
vault we need upon sacking the vault the
heavy cargo must then be taken back home
and winched out of the map all the while
you are being pursued by the opposition
team and the sheriff's troops i don't
know about you but that sounds like a
really good concept with this triple
dynamic at work i have high hopes for
hud
outlaws and legends on top of all this
are the different types of character you
can choose
a simple sniper like class using a bow
the hunter class has invisibility and
smoke bombs
the brawler is the tank of the group and
is also a mystical healing class
i'll see you on the battlefield on may
10th on playstation 4 and 5
xbox one and newer and pc
[Music]
sometimes we all need a break from
battle royale but we still want some
fast paced action
how about video game dodge ball knockout
city is ea's new action sports title
in which we literally play dodgeball and
as it says in the bible if you can dodge
a wrench
you can dodge a ball knockout city takes
what you know about dodgeball and cranks
it up to 11.
we can catch the ball and return fire
but those action elements really come
into play with physical attacks
there's no white line we can't cross
here if you can't hit them with a ball
hit them with a shoulder to the face the
skill elements come in with curved shots
looped shots and get this one
our teammates can literally become a
ball to be thrown at the opposition
knockout city is scheduled for a may
21st release
but here's a few things you should know
a free version of the game will be
available on release
but we don't know how long it will be
free for an announcement
must be imminent and i wouldn't be
surprised if the game drops its 20
price tag and becomes a completely free
to play battle pass focused experience
the last game in this vein rocket arena
bombed hard due to charging an upfront
fee
i hope they don't make the same mistake
twice anyway an announcement any day now
i know my luck it'll be seven minutes
after i post this video
so here's another free game and this
time no potential strings attached
enlisted an mmo world war ii shooter
and here's the thing it's already out
enlisted is made by the people who made
other free-to-play games like cuisine
royale
war thunder and crossout this time we'll
be reenacting battles from world war ii
with a brand new mechanic we can control
a squad of soldiers
each with their own role like infantry
sniper riflemen those kinds of things
but here's the kicker we only control
one of those men at a time
and the ai follows in our footsteps that
way our influence on the battle is more
extensive
than being a single chess pawn so
running solo is now effectively a team
thing
the battlefield includes vehicles like
historical tanks keeping gameplay varied
i'm definitely interested to try this
how do you feel about another world war
2 shooter though
enlisted is officially in beta right now
and can be played on pc ps5 and xbox one
sadly there is not a last gen option on
this one
the mass effect series is synonymous
with greatness even though the latter
days
were a little wider of the mark on may
14th
it's time to replay the mass effect
trilogy in this legendary edition
what is not worthy right away is that
this is a last gen title
a remaster staying humble and not over
promising which is good to see
the ps4 and xbox one versions will of
course be playable on ps5 and the latest
xboxes
the mass effect legendary edition
visually enhances all three games and
gives them the same aesthetic
the load times and other technical
issues have been ironed out
and tweaks to gameplay have been made
which is good news about the game which
is 14 years old
the core action rpg elements remain the
focus and get this in your ear holes
over 40 dlcs are included too
this series will take over your life if
you're not careful but commander shepard
is counting on you
may the 14th to replay a classic of our
time on ps4 xbox one and pc
next we have a dlc subnautica below zero
the base game was free on playstation
last month so if you grab that you're
already a step ahead
subnautica is a survival title set on an
underwater world
and as the title suggests below zero
takes us under the freezing point
adding another level of complexity to
staying not dead
new plant life to discover new
inhabitants to locate and tentatively
decide if they are hostile
and we are told this expansion includes
much more above water exploration than
ever before
other core mechanics have been added
like a ton of new gadgets to aid your
survival
so what are you waiting for planet 454c
arrives on may 14th on ps4 ps5 xbox one
and higher
pc and switch
[Music]
a couple of months ago a rust revival
took over every streamer's life and
became one of the most played
games on twitch well finally on may 21st
console players can find out what the
fuss is about
rust is another survival game yeah
there's lots on the list this month
the objective is simple survive the
wilderness starting off as a near-naked
dude with a rock in hand
and evolving your existence with
everything you pick up
players manage hunger thirst and are
constantly at threat from wildlife like
bears and wolves
ai characters can be found in the world
too who can be defeated
bringing in the core mechanic taking
other people's loot
as this is online there's no one
stopping players from offing each other
and taking away all your hard work
on respawn we're back to being a dude
with a rock
building a secure home base and having
constant trust issues
is the overriding emotion here and i
can't wait to finally try it
rust comes to ps4 and xbox one on may
21st
no news just yet on a next-gen version
have you heard of biomutant an action
rpg announced in 2017.
well it's finally here biomutant is set
in a fully open world
in which we control a warrior surrounded
by mutated animals
our character is fully customizable so
embrace your inner furry
and build the anthropomorphic creature
you always identified us
the story is focused around the tree of
life becoming infected
we then venture off into the sprawling
world to put things right
each area of the world is split into a
different biome and the plot adapts to
the decisions you make whilst out there
with a fully dynamic weather system a
day night cycle and multiple vehicles to
find on enemies to face
biomutant is looking like it could be
special or it could be just another
breath of the wild clone
i'll take either option to be honest
biomutant arrives on may 25th
on ps4 xbox one and pc so there we have
it eight games to pass the time in may
2021
thanks for sticking around till the end
i'm adam from playstation grenade you're
awesome i'll see you next time